So this is actually a pretty tricky question. We've talked
a lot about vocabulary, but applying your knowledge can be
a little bit more difficult. But, let's start from the
bottom and work our way up. So we know that
negative 100,000 x is a term. That means that negative
100,000 itself is not a term on its own. So
that means that it's not a variable term or a
constant term, since it's part of a term. You'll learn more
about parts of terms in the next lesson.
We also know that since this is a number
and its value is not going to vary, negative
100,000 is not a variable. And in the same
way, since its value is fixed, it's a
constant. It's just a number. And since it's a
number that's multiplied by a variable over here, it's
a coefficient. So, negative 100,000 in this context is
a constant and a coefficient. Cool. Great job working
on all of this vocab in your first lesson.